the draft happens two weeks from tonight
there is your top
16. we're going to focus on the top five
this segment miles and i are going to
give you our thoughts
our hunches our guesses as to who the
top five picks will be
and here's a shock we both think it's
going to be trevor lawrence number one
to the jaguars we both think it's going
to be zach wilson number two
to the new york jets that's not even
worth discussing
miles how big of a shock would it be for
you if the jets don't take zack wilson
at two
that would be huge i think it would be a
huge shock because i think
based on everything that we've heard and
all the reporting that there's been out
of new york i mean
byu itself and steve young talking about
different stuff
it just seems like that is definitely
going to be the pick so
if it's not i mean kudos to the jets for
coming up with this big old smoke screen
and i also feel like the 49ers wouldn't
have traded up
to number three overall if they didn't
know or have at least a very very very
good idea
uh who the jets were going to pick at
number two overall so
i if it's not zach wilson i will maybe
fall out of my chair man
i think that would be very surprising
all right let's pivot then to number
three the san francisco 49ers who made
that trade up three weeks ago tomorrow
who do you think they will take as of
right now with two weeks to go
plenty of time to change your mind but
right now if they were putting a name on
the card what name do you think it would
be
okay i i think that uh you probably
influenced me on this because
earlier today you were talking about the
fact that the betting odds have changed
but i also saw a picture yesterday of
kyle shanahan
at justin fields pro day and i
recognized the look on his face
and he was just so smitten he just looks
smitten with justin fields and i've had
that look on my face a time or two as
well so
i'm gonna say justin fields at number
three overall to the san francisco 49ers
i'm bucking the chat i'm going with the
betting people
are you talking about the photo where
shanahan was masked down
talking to justin fields is that what
you're talking about look at that
there it is punch your mask up kyle
i mean first of all kyle's hey wait man
let's go next level kyle's trying to
give justin fields covid
so that whoever drafts him is going to
get a guy who's covet i'm
that's you know where's the police are
we not at the point in the pandemic
where we can
where we can have a little bit of a
laugh if you're not going to wear your
mask you set yourself up for that all
right
um i the betting odds have changed and
mac jones was the favorite to be number
three overall up until
just about earlier today pete demilita
sent me the points bet odds justin
fields is now
minus 125 to be the third overall pick
mac jones plus 100
and trey lance plus 450. jones had been
the overwhelming favorite now it's
fields and one of the things i can't
tell miles
how much of what's going on when you
hear this chatter maybe it's not jones
maybe it's not jones i feel like some of
it is
nfl network espn deliberately
making things interesting if you lock in
too much on one guy
now we got the first three picks we got
the first hour of the draft
there's no reason to tune in we know who
the first three picks are going to be
whether there is true uncertainty or not
it's influenced the betting markets
and the thing that i've said all along
if you're the 49ers and you make that
trade you give up three first round
picks and a third round pick for that
guy
if you don't have a pretty damn good
idea who that guy is
just the idea that well you know we're
gonna give up all this and we'll figure
it out later
who we're gonna take i feel like they
knew when they made the move and it's a
process of confirmation not elimination
so i'm going to stick with jones just
just because you said fields but it's
not going to surprise me now if it is
fields and there were people who thought
it was lance now lance is plus 450.
so maybe it'll end up being trey lance
but it is going to be a quarterback
that's the one thing we know
we just don't know which one all right
so you got fields at
three what do the falcons do
at four i think that the falcons
would then take trade lance because then
they set themselves up for quarterback
of the future
and you can then let him get you know a
little seasoning
behind matt ryan who's still your
quarterback of the present because look
they're gonna have matt ryan
especially after restructuring that
contract for another year
it just would make too much sense for
them
to hold on to matt ryan and you know the
reports have been that arthur blank
still thinks that matt ryan has
something left in the tank so
i think it would make sense if they get
a guy like treylan somebody who has not
played as much football as much college
football
as some of these other guys who are
available at the qb position
and then you allow him to really come in
and learn
the system really start to get
comfortable maybe you start wanting to
play him
in 2022 but i think by 2023 you feel
really comfortable you feel really good
and you got yourself a guy
see if the f if the falcons have mac
jones and trey lance available to them
at four i think at that point the chance
of trading down
goes up because i could see one of these
other teams that really want mac jones
that assume he's going to be gone
why are you shaking your head because
that wasn't the game
that wasn't i'm just saying no i'm not
saying you should have said that
i'm not saying you should have said that
i'm just saying i'm i'd be intrigued by
the possibility i'm not finding fault
with your pick
i'd be intrigued by the possibility of
the falcons trading out of that spot
and someone offering them something that
they can't refuse to come up and get mac
jones
i make the falcons i'll agree with you
that well you know what let's make it
interesting i'll say they'll go kyle
pitts
i think i'll go kyle pitts best
non-quarterback in the draft a guy who
who really should be a receiver he's
huge he's
fast he's going to be used like a
receiver he may be a better version of
jimmy graham
frankly by the time it's all said and
done and that's a high bar because when
he was at his best jimmy graham was one
of the best pass catching tight ends
we've ever seen
so i'll go kyle pitts to make it
interesting a guy they're going to draft
and use
not a guy they're going to draft and
develop okay that's fair i mean i like
kyle pitts too but i i think
that he also if you're gonna pick him
there he basically can develop into a
julio jones replacement as your top
guy because after julio jones last year
with all those issues with the hamstring
we don't really know exactly what julio
jones is going to be
in 2021 in 2022 so i think that's a good
pick to set them up going forward on
offense too
okay pick five cincinnati bengals who do
you have
i think they've got to go with sewell
left tackle out of oregon i think
especially because joe burrow got hurt
they have to find a replacement that's
really going to stick there
for andrew whitworth who they have
basically been trying to replace since
the end
of the 2016 season when he then went and
signed with the rams he's somebody
who plays with tenacity at left tackle
and i just feel like if you are the
bengals
and you get somebody like sewell left
tackle you know you've got your qb
you can fill in around in different
spots but that is a guy who is such a
good
athlete he's so strong and he talks
about you know coming in
and hitting guys with bad intentions
that's exactly what you want as a left
tackle and especially like i said after
joe burrow got hurt
you want to make sure that he is as
protected as possible going forward
got to do it got to do it penny sewell
but an opportunity to trade down
i believe whether it's your scenario if
mac jones is still there my scenario
if trey lance is still there bengals
very conservative
when it comes to making moves like that
they just as soon take the guy and not
play the game that maybe we wouldn't get
him if we go down a few spots
but they could get more lottery tickets
and miles one of my big beliefs when it
comes to the draft you're always better
off having
more lottery tickets more lottery
tickets more opportunities you're going
to scratch them off and you're going to
get yourself a winner
so that's something that i think they
should consider and they should be
working the phones and they shouldn't be
stubborn about that hey go back to last
year
they were bound to determine not to
trade out of that top spot no matter
what the miami dolphins offered well you
know what
if you'd taken the offer and gone to
five you got a bunch of extra stuff and
you could have had justin herbert
and you can't say you're going to be in
a worse spot if that ultimately happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports